[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24
emmanuel macron est à bruxelles pour son
dernier sommet européen comme président
du conseil de l'union européenne et
alors que le chef de l'état français est
affaiblie par la perte de la majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale sa
séquence diplomatique va durer une
semaine sommet européen à bruxelles
réunion du g7 en bavière et sommet de
l'otan à madrid avec sa réélection il
aurait pu être le dirigeant le plus
puissant de rang pour les cinq années
qui viennent mais avec le risque d'une
paralysie en france comment le chef de
l'état français va-t-il maintenir sa
dynamique européenne et son rôle de
leadership pour l'ukraine ce sommet est
historique puisqu'il devrait acter sa
candidature à l'union européenne la
question de l'élargissement se repose
donc notamment pour les pays des balkans
et pour la géorgie l'europe doit elle
revoir son processus et sera aussi
question de l'indépendance des européens
notamment énergétique à l'égard de la
russie alors que la guerre en ukraine
s'inscrit dans la durée alors ce sommet
est il un tournant pour l'europe on pose
la question à mes invités j'ai plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés pascal jaouen un bon
soir directrice générale de la fondation
robert schuman sortie donc de ce rapport
schuman sur l'europe états de l'union
2022 il vient de paraître aux éditions
marib et bienvenue à vous en face de
vous renaud girard bonsoir reporter et
chroniqueur internationale au figaro
auteur de quel diplomatie pour la france
et c'est aux éditions du cerf bienvenue
dans le débat nous avons également avec
nous le général jérôme pélisse tron dit
bonsoir soit vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de la revue défense nationale bienvenue
dans le débat et nous avons avec nous en
direct de kiev tetyana au garrot garko
va bonsoir à vous journalistes
responsable du département international
à l'ukraine crisis media center
bienvenue à vous un jour on retrouve
tout de suite notre correspondante à
bruxelles alix bourdon alix bonsoir est
ce qu'on peut dire finalement que c'est
historique pour l'europe ce qui se passe
à bruxelles aujourd'hui
j'ai écouté en tout cas beaucoup ici
qualifie déjà cette décision d'
historique et il est vrai qu'une
candidature de l'ukraine aurait paru
complètement inimaginable il ya encore
quelques mois alors le problème c'est
que ça fait pas mal grincer des dents du
côté des balkans occidentaux qui
frappent à la porte de l'union
européenne depuis très longtemps pour
certains on pense notamment à l'exemple
de la massive macédoine du nord inquiet
candidate officielle depuis 17 ans alors
en fait avant le début de la guerre en
ukraine le sujet de l'élargissement
c'était plutôt un sujet à éviter à
bruxelles en souvient qu'en 2019 la
france avait refusé justement à la
macédoine du nord et à l'albanie
l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion
en estimant finalement que l'union
européenne n'était pas prête à
accueillir de nouveaux membres et
qu'elle avait déjà du mal à marcher à 27
mais on voit avec cette journée de
sommet aujourd'hui entièrement quasiment
entièrement consacré à cette question de
l'élargissement qui lie à un véritable
changement de cap mais se pose bien sûr
la question de la réforme de la
gouvernance de l'union européenne avec
notamment la question de l' unanimité
sur certaines questions alors en
attendant vous le savez un la france
propose la création d'une communauté
politique européenne qui inclurait
d'ores et déjà l'ukraine et les pays des
balkans occidentaux
merci alix alix donc le bordeaux en
direct de bruxelles on va revenir sur
tous ces thèmes bien sûr parce qu'un
joint à tout d'abord c'était et c'est le
dernier sommet européen pour emmanuel
macron comme président du conseil de
l'europe est le premier pour un emmanuel
macron réélu mais plutôt affaibli par sa
majorité relative à l'assemblée quel est
l'impact selon vous de cet
affaiblissement sur son positionnement
dans l'union européenne sous son
leadership alors bon il reste le
représentant de la france au conseil
européen il a été réélu le 24 avril la
france est représentée par son président
conte au conseil européen hors période
cohabitation il sait pas une période de
cohabitation et donc il est le
représentant de la france est en effet
aujourd'hui c'est le conseil européen le
président bailly et charles michel à
quelques européens il réside et le
conseil de l'union l'union rencontre
deux jours enfin je la situation dans
laquelle la france se trouve depuis
dimanche soir j'allais dire c'est
c'est commun à tous les autres pays en
allemagne a pas un parti majoritaire en
chez nos voisins belges ouf néerlandais
c'est pareil il ya trois quatre cinq
partis en italie bolivien que draghi a
fait une union derrière lui après on
verra ce qui se passera en espagne ces
gouvernements dits minoritaires donc
vous n'avez pas de majorité puisque le
seul pays qui vote au scrutin
majoritaire c'est la france est donc là
en effet c'est lui revenu dans ce nid
inédit en france c'est evian france au
niveau européen elle verse une
normalisation de la france qui revient
des standards plus européen qu'on a
l'habitude d'avoir dans tous les pays
avec en effet les coalitions qui peuvent
paraître surprenante quand en effet en
allemagne à une grande coalition comme
on l'appelle entre la gauche et la
droite qui est inimaginable chez nous et
bien là aujourd'hui il va falloir que
toutes les bonnes volontés pro
européenne parce qu'il ya aussi des anti
européens qui sont rentrés à l'assemblée
nationale c'est un peu ce qui se passe
au parlement européen où les forces du
gdir de réseau travaille ensemble ce
texte par tex et c'est nouveau pour la
france mais c'est très habituel pour pur
pour l'europe renaud girard vous êtes
plus alarmistes vous c'est vrai que
mario draghi a une capacité fédératrice
olaf schulze il a maintenant la
stabilité de sa coalition est ce que
pourrait mener le maquereau est ce qu'il
conserve emmanuel macron sa capacité
d'initiative en europe oui tout à fait
parce que si vous voulez la constitution
de la vème république
non mais c'est pas du tout le
gouvernement et le président qui a des
en charge des relations internationales
pour lui mais le gouvernement de
gouverner avec une majorité relative
chez nous en france depuis les intérêts
publics le vote de confiance n'est pas
obligatoire même la déclaration de
politique générale n'est pas obligatoire
c'est la constitution donc en fait alors
on vous me direz il avoir une motion de
censure motion de censure on aurait une
alliance entre les députés lepénistes et
député mélenchonistes et les députés
gaullistes je n'y crois pas donc en fait
je pense que on a fait beaucoup on a
parlé de séismes etc à tout ça était un
des métaphores très exagéré je pense que
emmanuel macron a tout à fait les moyens
de gouverner et vous avez vu qu'il
s'était pas mal débrouillé dans ses
consultations et qui n'a fait un message
il a été il a été plus ou moins -
l'ongle est parfois trop long dans ses
allocutions emmanuel macron mais hier
soir il était il est il a fait huit
minutes donc ça voilà les gens ont pu le
suivre jusqu'au bout et c'est une île et
paris xi orsay sans que ça finalement
ses névroses qui peut voilà alors je
pense pas en revanche mais c'est un
autre thème je pense qu'en revanche ce
qui attend les européens dans le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne est
beaucoup plus problématique c'est
pour résumer je ne suis pas inquiet sur
le fonctionnement politique de la france
je suis inquiet sur le fonctionnement
politique de l'union européenne alors on
va y revenir justement général jérôme
pellistrandi de réaction peut-être
justement sur ces difficultés ou pas d'
emmanuel macron est-ce que ça a un
impact sur sa stature au niveau européen
donc comme nous l'avons dit nous non
plus vous vous aussi vous dire non alors
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement nos
partenaires européens on sait ont cette
culture de du compromis politique et
d'une forme de gouvernement sous forme
de coalition et puis il ne faut pas
oublier que depuis le départ du royaume
uni
des institutions européennes bon la
france a retrouvé une place
prépondérante d'autant plus qu'elle est
quand même membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité et c'est quand même
important dans le cas justement de la
question ukrainienne de la guerre avec
la russie tetiana au barco va comment
voit-on sa d'ukraine de kiev à ce qu
emmanuel macron pour vous il a toujours
un leadership fort en europe malgré ce
qui s'est passé en france je ne sais pas
si on l'a suivi à kiev mais j'en suis
quasiment certaine oui mais si on suit
où on suit tout ce qui se passe en
europe et outre-atlantique parce que ça
concerne nos concerne ça ça change aussi
le destin de l'ukraine donc on a bien
suivi le parcours fait par emmanuel
macron des prix surtout depuis le début
de la guerre mais à un peu les semaines
d'avant on l'a vu un modèle mc points
avec trois autres les deux rires opinion
ici à kifle 17 jours avec des propos
très fort de soutien en fait de
l'ukraine hôtes est même un peu surpris
parce que les propos étaient vraiment
tranchant et sur le support de l'ukraine
dans les situations difficiles donc il y
avait aussi le signal politique donc on
sait pas encore l'eau le résultat final
de ce sommet où des l'union européenne
que se déroule à bruxelles aujourd'hui
et demain mais tout porte à croire en
tout cas nous gardons nous les
ukrainiens on garde cet optimisme pour
la décision finale puisque les signes
sont plutôt positifs c'est un jour
historique je rappellerai que c'était
donc le chemin vers l'union européenne
est inscrit à partir de 2010 lors de la
constitution et retient c'est à dire
dans le texte fondateur de l'ukraine
donc c'est un choix civilisationnels et
bien sûr aujourd'hui même le statut de
candidat à devenir membres c'est une
chose qui est pour l'instant resté recul
parce que ça ouvrage chalon qui reste à
faire c'est il y aura plusieurs étapes
on le sait il y aura des réformes yards
et la procédure des négociations qui
peut durer bien sûr mais aujourd'hui
c'est surtout perçue comme un geste
politique de soutien sans précédent en
fait sans précédent et à fait nécessaire
pour l'ukraine aujourd'hui parce qu'en
étant en guerre c'est un signal de six
très clair envoyé à vladimir poutine qui
depuis quatre mois nous laisse pas très
inquiet pascal janin cet historique donc
vous reprendriez ce terme pur pour
l'europe c'est un tournant pour l'europe
ce qui se passe en en acceptant une
candidature comme celles de l'ukraine de
manière accélérée alors
la manière et scénariste et la procédure
depuis le 28 février date à laquelle ils
ont fait acte de candidature et la
décision qui peut être prise aujourd'hui
qui n'est pas la décision finale qu'est
la décision inaugural si je puis dire
parce que en effet ça a été accéléré
dans le sens où d'habitude les demandes
d'adhésion sont plus rares sont plus
longues là en effet en quatre mois on a
fait tous les examens mais maintenant
une fois qu'ils ont ce statut de
candidat j'ai dire c'est l'étape numéro
un c'est le début d'un processus c'est
le sait le commencement ces liens ils
sont pas états membres demain matin ni
mais c'est déjà ça déjà c'est déjà
quelque chose manifestement qu'ils aient
eu cette accélération c'est inédit en
une excuse mais c'est inédit la guerre
sur le continent un état agressé c'est
inédit depuis plus de trente ans donc on
a un première fois un état qui comme l'a
dit madame regarde depuis l'occident les
valeurs
occidental depuis plusieurs années et
pas seulement depuis le premier le 24
février donc on a en effet un état qui
regarde vers l'ouest vers les valeurs et
qui faisait tâche est un petit peu de ce
qui était son histoire russe et donc il
faut lui tendre la main ils ont fait la
demande c'est pas nous qui leur avons
fait ils ont fait la demande on a
accéléré peut-être parce que c'était
l'ukraine mais par contre on leur a bien
dit que la procédure toutes les
procédures rien que la procédure mais
toute la procédure à partir du moment où
ils sont aux candidats il va y avoir en
effet des choses qui vont être mises en
place et ça va prendre plusieurs la
justice par exemple
l'économie et tout ce qui est juridique
scopel l'acquis communautaire c'est à
toutes les lois européennes que nous
avons depuis 1950 donc ça pourrait
prendre au moins 7 en 10 ans une dizaine
d'années en règle générale ça peut être
plus rapide mais ça peut être en moyenne
10 ans parce qu'on ne les acceptera pas
avant qu'il soit prêt et puis vous avez
dit tout à l'heure aux objets rares
quelque chose qui a trait à tort il faut
que nous en soyons d'état de pouvoir les
accepter et qu'on venait en effet la
capacité de pouvoir les avoir à côté de
moi et financière l'union l'union
européenne c'est pas tellement la
capacité dans ce jeu c'est la capacité
organisationnelle pour prendre des
décisions pour pouvoir avancer parce que
si on est bloqué à 27 et quand les à
35,16 arena ça sera difficile pour eux
de pouvoir s'en sortir donc il faut
qu'on soit prêt aussi à remettre les
choses à zéro pour que l'on ne fasse
avancer les dossiers qui sont pour
l'instant rendre les choses difficiles
déjà 27 alors justement difficile à 27
et il y en a d'autres qui se plaignent
comme le premier ministre albanais il ya
eu un sommet des balkans pour avant
justement ce sommet de l'union
européenne à bruxelles le premier
ministre albanais qui en fait sur un ton
ironique a conseillé aux ukrainiens de
ne pas se faire d'illusions ce qu'il a
dit sur le statut de candidat accordé
par l'union européenne parce qu'il a
averti la macédoine du mot du nord et
candidate depuis 17 ans et si je n'ai
pas perdu le compte 1 dit il et
l'albanie depuis huit ans sans compter
d'ailleurs il ya la serbie la bosnie
aussi me semble-t-il la grèce serbie et
le monténégro la bosnie encore le statut
officiel et le monténégro mais elle le
souhaite probablement
attendu trois ans avoir de son statut de
candidat et la serbie est officiellement
candidate il est évident que la serbie
ait davantage prêtes à intégrer l'union
européenne que l'ukraine pour des
raisons de justice d'organisation du
gouvernement du système bancaire c'est
donc cette amertume de ces pays en fait
vous la comprenez ah bah oui je la
comprends très bien parce qu'ils se
disent c'est pas juste nous on attend
voilà maintenant non je comprends aussi
très bien le message
d'espoir
c'était très difficile pour les
européens de refuser
aux ukrainiens ce qu'ils demandaient
parce que c'est vrai qu'ils sont cet
engagement depuis maidan pour l'europe
encore faut-il qu'il soit prêt et c'est
vrai que jusque là le gouvernement
ukrainien texte était connu pour sa
corruption c'est-à-dire les c'était
encore plus corrompus que la russie si
vous voulez donc donc avec des
oligarques et c'est donc donc il ya du
travail a les jambes étaient là il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire mais le
problème ici qu'on a c'est que il faut
se méfier nous français si vous me posez
la question en tant que français en tant
que chrétien évidemment que je veux et
si je suis français moi je veux défendre
mes intérêts de français et je vois que
c'est plus on élargit plus la france
pays fondateurs ne va plus contrôlés
septembre avec l'allemagne jusqu'à
présent elles pouvaient en fait avoir un
pouvoir de v2 de veto sur les décisions
c'est france et allemagne on pouvait pas
passer au delà mais là elle risque de
perdre parce qu'une très grande dilution
aujourd'hui les polonais par exemple il
se moque totalement de ce qu'on pense à
paris si vous voulez il continue il a eu
des subventions agricoles
gigantesque avec d un effort français et
la france a beaucoup défendu la pologne
pour sa politique agricole et pour
qu'elles aient des financements agricole
une fois que la pologne les obtenir
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait elle s'est
précipitée pour acheter du matériel et
des armes américaines voilà donc voilà
donc non vous n'êtes pas attention je
dis attention sachons défendre nos
intérêts et on a un autre problème
majeur en europe c'est qu'on a fait un
choix stratégique dément faut le dire
c'était au sommet de ses partenaires
techniques au sommet d'orbec en 97 c'est
qu'on a préféré
l'élargissement à l'approfondissement
vous avez vu là le vous avez vu le le le
comment se réunit le conseil vous avez
eu la taille de la salle ils sont 27
daventry cette fête juste un petit test
avec vos amis à 27 qu'est ce qu'on va
voir comme film ce soir ensemble eh ben
vous y arriverez pas pendant tout est
donc c'est ça le problème et c'est le
problème c'est qu'on n'a pas lors de
l'élargissement on n'a pas pensé
puisqu'on n'a pas vous le pensez faire
un système qui marche c'était par
exemple avoir un directoire vous avez
parlé de l'onu mon général à l'onu qu'on
le veuille ou non il ya un directoire ce
sont les cinq membres permanents là il
n'y a pas de directoire en union
européenne et ça et
ça nous serons également à la paralysie
générale
il faut rajouter également un désintérêt
de la france à l'égard des institutions
européennes on a beaucoup d'eurodéputés
français qu'ils le sont par défaut on a
désinvesti la commission européenne et
un parcours pour la haute administration
points un fonctionnaire français passé
par bruxelles c'est un exil donc il ya
aussi cet aspect là il va falloir
réinvestir donc les instances
européennes pour pouvoir peser sur les
décisions pascal oui dans les balkans
ils n'ont pas tous le même statut
d'abord parce qu'il y en a qui sont
candidats avec ambition la problématique
de cet élargissement à les lire on
traîne affaiblissement des années dit
l'élargissement alors pour que ça soit
celui de 2004 que la géorgie ou ici
ce soir ou demain seule la moldavie et
l'ukraine leur ont
cédé question politique et reconnaît
obligés de les prendre parce qu'ils ont
vécu du mauvais côté du mur et on essaie
de se faire pardonner le fait que nous
ayons eu lé le chances d'être libéré en
1945 et eux nous rappelle bien que ça
était seulement possible en 90 donc il
ya quand même une différence et que donc
on doit payer pour ça voilà et donc il
faut qu'on soit d'accord d'accord avec
ça on le fait pour des raisons
politiques ukraine n est pas demain
encore dans l'union européenne et pour
les balkans c'est pareil on essaye de
faire en sorte qu'ils puissent avancer
mais il ya eu de leur part le souhait
qu'ils mettent en place les réformes qui
sont nombreuses et il ya le renault
gérard ford
par exemple des 1000 pages d'acer lui
notaire alençon où la serbie avait la
serbie
si le fait qu'il va l'être dans l'union
européenne ou s'ils veulent regarder
vers la russie c'est salir leur usage il
veut pas être à la fois regardant vers
enfin demandant l'adhésion à l'union
européenne et regardant vers la russie
donc on a besoin en effet de clarifier
les choses c'est ce que j'expliquais
pour connecter ça fonctionne parce que
qu'est ce que veulent les citoyens
européens c'est que même si on est 35 de
masse elle se pose c'est pas un problème
mais il faut que ça fonctionne qu'on
soit capable de délivrer des choses or
il ya peu de politiques qui sont
européennes on a en a que des politiques
d'appui et donc il va falloir qu'on
mette ensemble ce qu'on veut faire quels
sont les messages qu'on veut faire
passer pour qu'on ait fait ça puisse
fonctionner que ça ne puisse pas bloquer
son zoom on joue quand même que c'est
pas nous français en tout cas qui avons
abandonné tous ses pc pauvre pays de
l'est effectivement à l'emprise
stalinienne aux 45 parce que nous
n'avons pas été invités à la conférence
de yalta en fait à la corvée rende y
attaquent à partager l'europe n'y a pas
eu un seul pays de l'union européenne
actuelle qui étaient invités ce sont les
anglo saxons qui ont laissé qui ont
décidé de gaulle a pas été invités il
était furieux des uns qui ont laissé
toute l'europe de l'est à un esclavage à
à l'union tetiana un soluté tiana aux
gars qu'on va peut-être une réaction
justement de vous de votre part de kiev
face justement au fait que tous ces pays
frappent à la porte et finalement et
bien l'ukraine passe avant et donc eux
sont amers
oui en effet mais il y avait aussi
négocié négociations de notre miss
ministère des affaires étrangères avec
les pays en question qu'ils sont bien
exprimés publiquement qu'il n'était pas
justement contre le fait que l'ukraine
fassin première et ça s'est passé il ya
deux semaines a fait donc c'est à
c'était un pas important pour dire que
rien sur les circonstances dans
lesquelles l'ukraine vit aujourd'hui ce
sont pas des circonstances normales où
on peut discuter tranquillement ou la
durée d'au de cinq ans on peut pas se
projeter projetés d'ici dix ans on vit
chaque jour du jour au lendemain c'est
très difficile d'expliquer comme ça
pendant nos débats m'a fait tant qu'à la
guerre d'un office à lui dire que tout
le toujours tous les jours il ya
quelqu'un qui meurt et à creuser c'est
souvent quelqu'un que vous connaissez ce
souvent qu'il compte qui verra pas la
fin de cette histoire
il ya plusieurs qui n'ont pas lui-même
la libération de qui il faut tirer ni
gif ou celui qui n'ont pas vu la suite
de cette histoire donc nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans l'eau dans la question
du danger existentiel tout soutien qui
provient de nos partenaires occidentaux
est très apprécié même si bien sûr il ya
des conditions ou ça peut durer des
années aujourd'hui on fait face je vous
rappelle à un mal absolu est donc le mot
barbare
a
été prononcée par emmanuel macron les
mêmes qu'il est après son passage à
erding ça ouvre un policier quand on
voit quand on est présent quand on voit
à quoi ressemble cette agression russe
et quand on dit qu'on veut en europe ça
ne veut pas dire qu'on pense tout de
suite à ne partage de marchés à des
procédures juridiques on pense tout de
suite à se mettre du côté des laisses
civilisation parce que ce que nous avons
à face de nous nous voyons en et miki
extrêmement krill qui n'a aucune pitié
pour des civils on a eu des des choses
déjà incroyable rien qu'au mariupol avec
selon les estimations officielles vent
de 1000 civils qui sont morts avec les
tomes les tombes de masse donc c'est ce
sont des choses qu'on pouvait pas
imaginer on croyait avoir ça dans les
films et encore donc on se croit à la
frontière entre la civilisation et la
barbarie donc on veut bien sûr c'est
pour nous ça existe un style c'est ça je
crois les civilisations vous dit pascal
janin peut-être aura-t-on a su mêler
gestion jeu contre la russie donc je
pense en effet que l'adhésion que
veulent à l'ukraine c'est en effet pour
montrer qu'ils sont résolument engagés
vers l'ouest ils ont fait le choix
depuis plusieurs dirigeants politiques
de regarder plutôt vers les valeurs que
nous incarnons et ils sont aujourd'hui à
gré c'est donc en effet on leur doit en
effet un message qu'on leur donne pour
autant à partir de ce moment où ils
seront candidats ils vont subir comme
les pays des balkans les mêmes règles
les mêmes procédures les mêmes chapitres
donc c'est en effet le début d'une
aventure pour eux on les soutiendra mais
il va falloir qu'il fasse le plus gros
du travail c'est eux qui vont le faire
comme dans les pays des balkans olaf
scholz en tout cas le chancelier
allemand a réitéré son soutien à
l'ukraine il a balayé vous allez
l'entendre d'un revers de main tout
retour à une relation avec la russie un
partenariat avec la russie est
impossible dans un futur proche c'est ce
qu'il a dit le chancelier allemand on
les écoute on masque l'aps soyons clair
un partenariat avec la russie qui était
l'objectif stratégique de 2010 est
inimaginable à l'avenir avec la russie
agressive et impérialiste de poutine
franche terre
en ingérant perd quelques clarifications
là de la part de lifesize et des
allemands y compris d'ailleurs en termes
de politique énergétique
oui parce qu'en fait si vous voulez
il ya une décision de l'allemagne
que s'alimenter puisque ils ont pris
cette décision en fin angela merkel a
pris cette vision assez hâtive aman aman
a mon avis tu arrêter le nucléaire de se
reposer sur le gaz russe pour bat pour
pour alimenter les centrales de
production
d'électricité et c'était très important
pour eux ils ont fait ce gazoduc nord
stream 2 qui va directement du
territoire russe au territoire allemand
qui est achevée aujourd'hui qui pourrait
fonctionner aujourd'hui techniquement si
on ouvrait le robinet ce que les
allemands ne sont pas prêts à faire il
avait même été tellement loin les
allemands que les américains leur ont
demandé de ne pas faire ce projet ils
l'ont fait quand même donc c'était la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'europe que de l'histoire union de
l'europe oui que l'allemagne faisait des
choses contre l'avis des américains la
france en a fait plein mais là c'était
la première fois que l'allemagne le
faisait l'allemand quand il ya un
changement réel j on s'est dit il ya
plus de retour en arrière un changement
à son changement de stratégie
maintenant je pense qu'il faut pas non
plus se sert à rien d'isoler la russie à
moi je ne pense pas que la russie
soit la barbarie la guerre c'est la
barre bail et dans la boue dans la
guerre il ya de la barbarie et la russie
ce n'est pas la barbarie et puis nous
européens nous n'avons pas deux à donner
puisque la barbarie a eu était allemande
1,11 vide s'était dirigé par les
allemands pas parler russe est bien
aussi de la barbarie en russie sous
staline et puis en ukraine en 41 bon là
c'était pas voilà la civilisation 1 le
nationalisme ukrainien
donc là encore on nous ment
je pense non je pense que je pense que
ce qu'a fait vladimir poutine est
inacceptable dans les relations
internationales à l'ukraine était tapi
reconnue par la russie donc ça c'est
inacceptable d'envahir un pays que vous
avez vous même reconnu et que dont vous
avez vous même volontairement reconnu
l'indépendance ça c'est une chose mais
pas ailleurs je pense qu'à très long
terme et ça ils auraient pu le dire à
très long terme bien sûr que la russie a
vocation à revenir dans la famille
européenne la russie et de culture
européenne la vocation est à revenir
dans cette famille européenne par
n'entend pas avec ses chars et ses
invasions mais sûr mais avec sa culture
et nous ferions une erreur stratégique
de pousser à long terme la russie dans
les bras des chinois est générale vous
êtes d'accord à ce que vient de dire aux
nageurs parce qu'effectivement olaf
scholz on et j'étais un peu étonné en
voyant son discours parce
qu'effectivement il ne parle pas que de
court terme à il dit c'est terminé
maintenant la relation avec un aussi
telle qu'elle a pu exister avant donc
l'impact de la guerre en ukraine est
très profond et va durer oui en
architecture sécuritaire de l'europe
nous ans nous entrons dans le cinquième
mois de guerre et très sincèrement je
pense que aujourd'hui il ne peut plus y
avoir de relations normales avec la
alors ne pas dire avec la russie mais
avec la russie de vladimir poutine c'est
à dire qu' il faudra attendre
que poutine parts que ce soit de mort
naturelle ou autre autres pour
éventuellement
réintroduire
dialoguer mais en l'état actuel on voit
bien que blague libre poutine a à jouer
non pas aux échecs mais un coup de poker
pensant qu'il pouvait profiter d'une
fenêtre d'opportunité pour tout
bousculer c'est un échec militaire quoi
qu'on dise pour lui il n'a plus les
moyens même si il s'agite envers la
lituanie ou ainsi de suite son outil
militaire est dans un état désastreux
même si pour le moment sur le terrain il
fait des dégâts considérables et donc
nous rendre dans une période de
quarantaine ou de guerre froide qui va
durer extrêmement extrêmement longtemps
bien sûr un jour il faudra mais le jour
est loin d'être arrivée pascal janin ce
jour est ce qu'il va arriver là pour
l'instant phénomène positionnement alors
lié à la france un qui dit la france
peut peut se passer du gaz russe dans
l'absolu c'est ce que vient de dire la
ministre panière une hache et donc on
sent bien que les européens jouent cette
question d'indépendance énergétique à
l'égard de la russie et que la
chose comme l'a dit le renaud girard ils
étaient pieds et mains liés à la russie
de manière dramatique et à tel point de
dépendance qu'on se demandait en effet
aurait été leur cécité parce que ça
allait bien en tant que ça marchait puis
le jour ça marche plus voilà ils ont
donc olaf scholz qui viennent à partie
en plus où il ya quand même eu beaucoup
d'accointances avec la russie et je
rappelle que le spd s'offre son
prédécesseur immédiat du spd puisque il
ya eu même merkel pendant 16 ans vers le
plus ancien chancelier avant lui sp des
fraudeurs et l agent de l'entreprise
russe et il a démissionné vraiment
vraiment dans l'est dans les derniers
jours il a mis longtemps avant de
prendre conscience des choses on est en
effet une radical changement est fêtée
tous les excès parce qu'entre trop et
plus rien il ya le juste milieu là
aujourd'hui il est certain que pour les
européens la négociation avec vladimir
poutine
c'est pas possible or seul le présent
français avaient la possibilité d'avoir
un dialogue avec la dirigeante au team
et ça lui a été reproché par tous les
autres parce qu'on visait à quoi ça sert
ça sert à quand on est le seul à pouvoir
avoir une ligne avec un dirigeant qui
est quand même avec c'est bien de
l'avoir et on l'a pourquoi tout
simplement parce qu'on est la seule
puissance nucléaire membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité et qui a pas
d'autres européens autour de la table
qui peut avoir cette même discussion
avec la nuit mais quand cantate quand et
yao par cora parle de guerre de
civilisation bien on va beaucoup plus
loin où quand on lave shouldice est
terminée il n'y aura plus ses liens avec
la russie qu'on aime c'est une guerre
abjecte c'est une guerre en effet qui
fait qu'en effet les lélés les os
crânien sont en effet pro pro fasse
aussi bien plus européen mais les russes
ne sont pas non plus aujourd'hui
il y avait dit mi-août il mais il ya une
société russe etc on a avoué que son
monarque unifié les amériques on a
terminé non on a un voisinage immédiat
avec la lala avec la russie donc on peut
espérer que mes temps je sais pas dans
combien de temps parce que la guerre est
toujours présente à travers qu'on
discute avec le voisin à un moment tu
aimais pas maintenant mais on attend
dans le présent en attendant on
s'organise n'est ce pas pour qu'il y ait
des sanctions
il faut se passer du gaz russe où on
aurait fait l'ukraine qui est agression
lui dis venez dans le club on vous
accueillera un jouet en donne un signal
politique ce soir qui est aussi envoyer
à moscou parce qu'on leur vie bah voilà
vous avez déclenché quelque chose qu'on
n'aurait pas fait sans que vous ayez
déclaré la gamme juge denny chin fera at
il qualifié de barbares les américains
pour avoir déclenché une guerre
d'invasion de l'irak j'aurai un mensonge
en 2003 où il ya deux cent mille
personnes qui sont morts et s'être
retirés ensuite pour y laisser l'état
islamique prendre me saoule mesure je
fais du besoin d'eux mais j'espère l'ont
donc si vous voulez moi en 2003 j'ai
bien sûr condamné dès le départ
l'invasion américaine de l'irak mais je
n'ai pas dit que les états unis
d'amérique c'est la barbarie hornets ne
dis pas que la russie c'est la barbarie
est-ce que la russie est une démocratie
la réponse non ce n'est pas une
démocratie ce n'est pas la barbarie est
ce qu'il ya des actes barbares dans la
guerre oui malheureusement les russes
eux ont commis des actes barbares et les
ukrainiens ou si on en parle moins mais
aussi l'exact barbares commis par les
ukrainiens dans cette guerre tetiana
hoggar covage à moins que vous agissiez
justement est reçue sur justement cette
décision de relève chose quand il a dit
il n'y aura plus de liens avec la russie
comme auparavant est ce que pour vous
qui est ukrainienne la russie s'est
terminée ce sera plus comme avant quoi
qu'il arrive même à l'après poutine on
salue cette fermeté de la chose qui
n'était pas le cas il ya quelques
semaines il y a aussi le l'histoire de
désarmement qui arrive un peu lentement
en ukraine notamment je parle des
armements allemand pour l'udc en
question voilà de lyon entre l'ukraine
et la russie c'est exclu difficile hier
j'ai vu un film réalisé par un
réalisateur russe qui a fait que tu
essaies d'un film sur des ruptures un
film documentaire en fait il a en parlé
avec plusieurs familles russes où il ya
justement des ruptures entre les gens
qui sont pour la guerre la grande
majorité on dirait selon les sondages
sociologique et le chiffre s'élève
jusqu'à 85% et après une minorité
d'autre peut tous les jeunes qui se sont
vraiment d'une manière très heureuse
aujourd'hui parce qu'il n'approuve pas
ce que la russie de vladimir poutine
fait et donc et j'étais frappé quand je
regardais ce film parce qu'il ya une
chose qui me revenait après je me suis
rendu compte que c'était et c'est une
chose que vous connaissez très bien on
vous en france
johnny en esko rhinocéros donc cette
pièce de théâtre d'absurde lundi creek
au moment où les gens sont informés
rhinocéros c'est un peu ça c'est un peu
l'image qui me revient à la tête quand
je vois les gens normaux physiquement
qui commencent à sortir des choses
absolument absurde qui disent que la
russie mène une guerre de deux juste une
guerre de libération qui sont fier des
leurs et grands de re sic en puissance
et la propagande russe à laquelle vous
faites quand il se lève de jaune ou en
font enfin il distille tout le monde a
peur de nous c'est à dire que ça veut
dire pour nous que poutine a bien raison
tout le monde les pauvres allemand
français les héros payant les ports
ukrainiens donc à fond on est on est
chef ici je vois ça je pense tout de
suite à ionesco est donc re lisez cette
pièce de théâtre et donc vous allez voir
un peu l'image comme come on on perçoit
les les russes aujourd'hui donc ça veut
dire c'est aujourd'hui où c'est pour
longtemps les traces vont laisser des
marques longtemps oui poutine la poutine
c'était ça aussi la question il y a une
chose il ya un mot qui n'a pas été
prononcé lors de ce débat et qui
nécessaire c'est le mot la défaite ce
qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est la défaite
militaire diplomatique n'importe
laquelle des lèvres aussi sans la
défaite totale et aura pas de changement
de régime il y aura pas de changement
historique pour la russie donc michon
les compromis ça marchera pas donc il
faut une dose fait il ya un long chant
de de repentir en fait de la
reconnaissance des crimes puisque sans
ça il ya énormément il ya des millions
de gens qui qui vivent dans l'air et
télé réalité de la propagande russe qui
croit ce qu'elle voit dans les écrans en
fait et donc comme des véritables les
rhinocéros top il faut cette
reconnaissance est faux je le dis déjà
plusieurs fois il faut amuser de marque
paul au centre de moscou il faut qu'il
ya des écoliers qui vient de voir ce que
leurs parents ont fait je sens qu'ils
aient cette reconnaissance de la faute
historique un site bien sûr les
reussilles ils peuvent revivre comme
tous les pics ont commis des crimes ils
peuvent revivre on va rétablir des liens
il ya beaucoup de clients qui ont de la
famille à rossi vice versa donc il ya
des choses il y aura le processus de la
réconciliation mais il faut d'abord
d'abord partir pour l'inde et la défaite
militaire d'abord et long processus de
la reconnaissance et bien sûr
préparation aussi financière a appuyé le
crâne et ensuite on pourra revivre
compte des pieds voisins qu'on députés
indépendants les ans les autres il
demande à la paix et avant ça vous avez
besoin de l'europe renaud girard une
remarque en tête je vois qu'il 19h45 et
je sais que vous devez quitter ce
plateau
devenant je pense qu'effectivement les
liens si vous voulez quand vous allez je
reviens de kiev les liens sont très
profonds quand même entre
c'est des liens de culture si vous
voulez les jeunes quand ils s'adressent
à vous quelques fois ils s'adressent
exprès d'ukrainiens pour montrer cette
année entre eux dans les packs à kiev
ils se parlent russe les gens se parlent
au kef est une ville russophone alors ça
veut pas dire que genève est une ville
francophone ça veut pas dire que c'est
la france voit la 3d tout à fait c'est
tout affecté pas mais je pense que la
bonne moi je pense que la bonne solution
la bonne diplomatie c'est celle ci et
moi d'être cocorico et c'est celle
d'emmanuel macro c'est dire toi à la
fois on parle aux russes mais à la fois
on livre des âmes efficace
à l'ukraine terme à ces fameux canons
caesar alors que les allemands et ça m'a
été dit hier à kiev ont fait beaucoup de
promesses là il ya des quasi insulte à
l'égard de la russie mais aucune
livraison sur le terrain eh bien je
pense que macro a raison il faut établir
un rapport de force avec la russie c'est
très important parce que ils ne vont
comprendre que ça mais il ne faut pas
boucher l'avenir nous avons vocation
nous français à être voilà il ya un pont
alexandre iii à paris à être évidemment
ramener la russie dans la famille
européenne je pense que je pense que
effectivement quand bien même il aurait
même été
attiré dans ce piège par les américains
dans le piège de la guerre est bien
poutine y est tombée très volontiers et
donc on ne peut pas approuver ce qu'il a
fait il faut soutenir aujourd'hui le
cren de toutes les manières qu'on peut
et donc ça fait partie évidemment ce
processus de candidature pascale joannin
fait partie de ce support vous disiez ça
les valeurs de l'europe et ça doit aider
les ukrainiens effectivement au moins à
retrouver le moral on entendait beaucoup
ça dans les rue d'odessa aujourd'hui où
nous avons une envoyée spéciale il fera
pas oublier la moldavie parce que c'est
un petit pays un mais il va avoir aussi
le statut parce que c'est un pays divisé
aussi à aider là pour le coup il ya une
une armée russe qui est là du côté de
cette région séparatiste
sécessionniste qui n'est reconnu par
personne la transnistrie et donc ils ont
aujourd'hui des femmes au pouvoir en
moldavie
de son trait aux pro européenne ils sont
très présents au ps mais il ya aussi des
pro russes donc il faut se méfier donc
aussi ce ticket qu'ils heures serait
donné c'est aussi pour montrer que
l'engagement européen s'il est pérenne
en moldavie ça paiera il faut éviter que
le retour à des suppôts de moscou
arrivent de nouveaux pouvoirs c'est une
nouvelle façon finalement pour l'europe
d'accepter les uns et les autres ou
est-ce que ça rapproche un petit peu on
se souvient quand même des années 90
avec justement le l'effondrement de
l'union soviétique et cette entrée de
tout des pays baltes à plein peut aussi
c'est une sorte de soutien déjà à
l'époque avait les pays baltes
aujourd'hui c'est son le ce qu'ils sont
cons devrait écouter malheur mais
véritablement parce que eux ils
connaissent le régime russe fas ou
soviétique puisque des de tous les états
membres qui existent aujourd'hui qui
était de l'est ce sont les trois seuls
qui était dans ce qu'on appelait l'urss
dont qu'ils ont cet essai gravé dans
leur mémoire et c'est donc ces
événements qu'il croyait ne plus revivre
d'une agression par la russie d'un pays
eux ils savent que ça scouts et pour
leurs parents et leurs grands-parents
etc donc on doit les écouter et donc là
il faut qu'en effet d'ailleurs les pays
d'europe centrale soit écoutée et pas
que la pologne et la hongrie les pays
baltes parce que nous avons peut-être
beaucoup apprendre nous français
allemand et italien de ce qui a été le
l'histoire de ceux de sept de ces pays
et donne les écouter dans ce qui
pourrait être en effet une solution
alors pas à court terme et à long terme
pays baltes 1 qui sont dans l'otan
également general donc il ya une
certaine concurrence aujourd'hui entre
l'otan et l'union européenne un petit
peu il y à concurrence mais on voit
aussi que la guerre déclenchée le 24
février à oblige les deux organisations
davantage discuter et à coopérer
d'ailleurs c'est ce que le plan macro on
dit à quelqu'un à l'occasion du sommet
donc les deux institutions d'abord bon
ça fait longtemps qu'elle travaille
ensemble il faut approfondir parce que
il ya bien sûr les pays baltes et pia et
c'est aussi la question des balkans qui
est quand même un enjeu très à bord et
tout est lié c'est à dire que cette
partie de l'europe et une partie fragile
dont les difficultés sont accrues par la
guerre provoque et la russie et donc il
faut avoir une approche globale qui va
s'inscrire bien sûr dans la durée une
assise contre la russie c'est sa une une
approche alors une approche globale de
l'ensemble des problèmes avec le facteur
aggravant qu'est la russie mais
n'oublions pas par non plus si le rôle
très ambigu de la turquie membre de
l'otan
aussi candidate
oui quand des dons on voit le
durcissement des relations avec la grèce
d'ailleurs ces derniers jours alors il
nous reste 5 minutes j'aimerais qu'on
entend de frans timmermans quel
responsable de la politique climatique
justement au sein de l'union européenne
il parle de l'approvisionnement en gaz
justement on va l'écouter
même si les états membres qui ont
réitéré leur attachement aux principes
d'efficacité énergétique d'abord donc le
résonnement repose sur un mécanisme de
partage des charges juste et équilibrée
il ne pourra pas nous diviser d'as parce
que j'en ai c'est la problématique du
gaz là on voit effectivement qu'il en
est question à bruxelles que la france
se dit qu'elle va être autonome très
vite clairement une redéfinition de
cette indépendance européenne à l'égard
du gaz russe et ça ça va durer c'est
quelque chose ah oui mais il faut il
faut il faut être il faudrait être dans
les règles il faudrait être aveugle
premier niveau dallaire pardon si on
veut organiser battre poutine et donc
gay faire gagner les ukrainiens en leur
livrant des âmes sans être des
combattants nous mêmes sur le terrain il
ya une arme l'énergie on paye tous les
jours une somme à la russie donc si on
veut plus leur donner d'argent il faut
qu'on trouve d'autres alternatives par
le sud l'algérie par la norvège etc on a
aujourd'hui un accès rapide aux chardons
il ya des risques sur le charbon
précision le gazole on a un accord mais
pas d'accord pas d'accord sur le gaz et
donc ça va être le gros point mais
aujourd'hui la plupart des états membres
ont dit on va faire toutes les réserves
que l'on peut pour essayer de ne pas
subir au niveau de l'hiver qui va
arriver ce qu'on est au début de l'été
la menace justement pour éviter d'être
dépendant pour les pays qui sont
vraiment dépendant alors nous la france
dont les un peu moins avec le nucléaire
mais d'autres qu'ils ont fait le choix
inverse pour éviter d'être encore plus
tributaire de vraies mais justement
général là le risque d'une rupture
totale de l'approvisionnement en gaz est
aujourd'hui plus réel que jamais c'est
ce qu'il dit un frans timmermans oui
tout à fait et donc ça va être la
difficulté puisque même si on pense
davantage à la chaleur et aux vacances
il faut d'ores et déjà préparer et donc
cet hiver et on voit bien que les
positions là vont être différente d'un
pays à l'autre certains pays seront
prêts à se passer du gaz russe on peut
penser à la pologne qui préférera
prendre des douches froides plutôt que
de consommer à mètres cubes de gaz russe
mais bien sûr la problématique c'est
l'allemagne qui est le plus gros
importateur donc on voit que les
semaines à venir vont être compliqués
sur ces négociations et là dessus avec
la préoccupation bien sûr climatique
doit-on rouvrir des mines de charbon
poursuivre l'exploitation des mines de
charbon c'est ce qui se passe déjà en
allemagne ce qui se passe en allemagne
sans accord en effet que mir elvis de
gaz et qu'ils ont plus de centrales
nucléaires ou qui veulent pas les
rouvrir en effet ils refont du charbon
et aux gens les verts au pouvoir oui et
malgré tout les verreries ivoire mais et
avec un nécessité fait loi mais les
énergies alternatives comme l'éolien et
bien dépendent énormément des conditions
météo et par exemple l'année dernière le
vent était faible la production éolienne
a été faible donc autant d'éléments et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
qu'une réponse européenne ou et
bruxelles va jouer un rôle important
pour trouver des compromis oui des
compromis mais enfin pour l'instant
effectivement il ya urgence il ya
peut-être ailleurs une prolongation de
trois réacteurs nucléaires en allemagne
ça serait possible si c'est possible
dans la mesure où les règles les
réacteurs nucléaires allemands sont très
bien entretenus donc c'est possible de
les prolonger vous savez que la décision
qui avait été prise par angela merkel
était d'abord politique dans le cadre de
donc d'alliance
électorale là on voit bien que le
problème se pose au t il ce projet à
court terme mais aussi à long terme
parce qu'il va falloir avoir des
solutions pérennes qui s'inscrivent dans
la durée bien sûr pour la france mais
aussi pour tous les partenaires
européens d'autant plus que vladimir
poutine utilise larmes du gaz puisqu'on
voit déjà qu'il le fait exprès alors bon
on était une période où c'est moins
critique mais il est capable en effet
d'arrêter le robinet est donc là en
effet c'est une c'est une obligation
pour les états membres qui sont
indépendants de trouver des moyens donc
de faire ses réserves avant le 1er
novembre
et puis de se désengager et donc là on
est tous les alternatives des
alternatives et je ne peux pas être que
des renouvelables parce que le
renouvelable ne peut pas remplacer en
effet pour l'instant en l'état actuel
des choses tout les toutes les énergies
et avec un narratif russin voulons
imputer la responsabilité
bien sûr aux dirigeants européens tant
pour la problématique de l'énergie que
là pour la problématique des céréales
que l'ukraine ne peut pas exporter donc
dire c'est la faute des occidentaux
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous en
tout cas général jérôme pellistrandi
merci pascal jouanno merci à vous
tetyana hoggar kova d'avoir été avec
nous en direct de kiev merci arnaud
gérard qui étaient avec nous il ya
quelques instants et puis merci à l'iss
le bourdon qui a fait l'ouverture de ce
débat en direct de bruxelles merci à
vous tous en régie
[Musique]